foreign
the warmest place in the U.S Fairbanks
Alaska what's up I think that's where
Oates Military Academy is what's up
Sarah
hi Dr John how are you good that was my
uh Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure
reference for those of you who weren't
paying attention so what's up
hey yeah so I'm just going to start with
my question
um how do I support my husband and focus
on repairing our marriage when he is
constantly worried about his health
tell me more
does he have cancer or does he have
um like hormone disruption like does he
have health issues or
what's going on
no he doesn't have cancer
um oh no yeah okay oh man I can hear it
oh honey you are real real real close to
resenting him is he like a is he is he
like a
is he like that guy on Sleepless in
Seattle
uh an ailment or a thing or his knee
hurts or he's going for a walk with the
kids and he's got to put like an ankle
brace on and he always has like I think
I've got a thing and he goes to the ER a
lot
yeah
I can hear that in your exhale
yeah I mean I I don't I don't I wouldn't
say you know he'd like goes to extend up
putting like ankle braces on and such
but
um
I I would say that
um
I mean
I would think so yes
okay give me an example
oh um my
for example I mean he'll come home and
say
that he thinks his his gallbladder you
know is giving out or
um you know he'll Google like the
silliest things like if there's a red
mark on his hand he'll Google it because
he won't be sure if it's something
serious or not gotcha okay
gotcha
um how long have you been his mom
probably too long yeah
and it's weird trying to sleep with your
son huh
and I mean that in all of the awkward
gross ways it just sounded when I said
it the whole thing right as soon as you
start getting in a caretaker role and
then you become like a you're fine honey
and he's like am I fine and there gets
this awkward Dynamic then the last thing
on earth is intimacy and sexual desire
and that turns into his anxiety things
spinning faster
which in his case creates more
well what about this and my my fingers
hurt and then all of a sudden
I mean you see how like y'all getting
this dance now and it just it y'all end
up you're like all right I'm done
so can I ask you a real real hard
question
yeah
um
is there somebody else for you
um
I don't know I mean you do
or maybe it's not all the way there yet
but almost or man it would be nice if
it would be nice if yeah that's all you
have to say I won't push you on that
anymore
um I
and again I'm going back to that single
exhale I could hear it
like you're you're at the end
or let me see it this way
you have put a lot of this on him
you don't like who you have become
yes and no
um I know this is all him
I mean no no I definitely like owned to
my mistakes
um 100 but I do I just feel like
um we've only been married for going on
almost four years so I feel like
majority of the time we haven't really
been in a happy marriage
yeah so that's sad to say
um yeah I feel like there's been more
stressful times than happy times
what's what's the root of the of the the
unhappiness
um
I know you've thought about it because
you've had imaginary conversations with
him that you've never said out loud like
you've you at least in your guts believe
this all starts at a place where is that
place what is it
I don't
I don't know I feel like there's just
two there's too much I feel like that's
gone wrong it's like what's gonna go
right
I
I asked him the other day and he he told
me that he thought that
um my parents were the reason that
our marriage is so bad are they
partially
why do you allow that
setting boundaries okay
have you wanted to set boundaries
between the
uh
have I wanted to yeah
yeah absolutely let me say it this way
do you want to get closer to him
yeah
do you like the way things are right now
what's stopping you from making them
different you're you're an adult in the
United States you can kind of do
whatever you want except for like
shrooms and stuff
right what do you want to do
and when I say like you don't like who
you're becoming here's what I mean not
that you've said mean things and haven't
done bad hey you know haven't put
boundaries out whatever
you had a picture of yourself
and you had a picture of your marriage
like a woman that got was taken care of
or that was super sexy or you were
married with a guy and you'd go do crazy
fun things
and he would punch the guy at the bar
who was mouthing off to his wife and I'm
just making up crap right but you had a
picture of what this looked like
and now you got kids
yeah how old
uh two and one oh good God Almighty so
okay so you've been married four in an
unhappy marriage and you got two
toddlers which are just incredible for
your sex life and you are now
a
woman who goes to work
and you have your uh somebody else makes
your heart beat a little bit faster
you're an exhausted mother of two really
you're an exhausted mother of three
and your husband's way of getting
attention from you
his way of finding meaning in your
marriage and your partnership is
something's wrong with me that I need
you to help or I need you to feel sorry
for me that's his entry point with you
and that's what I mean you just don't
like who this the you in this
yeah I would agree with that fear
yeah for sure
so what do you do next
um well
we're in the process of moving for for a
start
um
and is also
working on
getting better health care
for himself
nope
um timeout
what are you going to do
uh uh let me put its way are you done
well one are you done go ahead are you
done with them not with me with with the
marriage are you finished so if we're
finished let's just be finished
no
do you want to stay married and build a
life for this guy
yes
do you want him to be your husband to be
the father of your kids he already is
the father of your kids but do you want
to create a tightly woven together
new picture with this dude
yeah absolutely
you just saying that
no okay
then we're going to start by we're gonna
stop judging him okay it's a waste of
time it doesn't help
when's the last time you sat down and
looked at him and said your needs out
loud very very clearly
I have no idea
let's start there because at the end of
the day that's all you can control
you can't control whether he feels a
lump on the side of his leg or if he's
got a weird mold that he feels like he's
got to go to the ER about you can't
control any of that
can control how honest you are with him
yeah
and you can control your needs
hey I need this from you
and I need you to go get some
to go see a counselor because we've gone
to the ER a bunch we've gone to the
doctor a bunch and none of the things
that have happened so far have proven to
be uh life-threatening or even medical
ailments and so I'm concerned there's
something else going on and I'm happy to
go with you
and if you don't want to go that's fine
I'm gonna go for me
because I want to learn how to love you
better and right now I'm not doing a
great job
mm-hmm
see what I'm saying and those are hard
conversations
foreign yeah yeah absolutely
okay what are you thinking
you're shutting down on me don't shut
down
uh I don't know it's just
it's a lot
um
although I mean he hasn't been diagnosed
with anxiety but I do feel like he does
have really bad anxiety and I don't
as you just described and that's that's
what it sounds like
what do you mean
he sounds like a guy with a ton of
anxiety
and having been one of those myself and
having had some really really
uncomfortable conversations with my wife
over the years being married to somebody
who has deep and profound anxiety is
Madness
it's exhausting
and you ultimately have to create a
world that only you and your kids
inhabit because your partner's
electrified it's like being married to a
taser it's not safe
and you didn't get married to have to
build a life on your own inside of a
cocoon
you also didn't get married to be a
third to have a third kid
who's in an adult body
so I'm I'm I'm I'm
understanding having done what he has
done done to you I've done that to my
wife so I get it it's awful
and the only way he heals is through
connection that's not to put the burden
on you he's gonna have to reach out and
decide he wants to go get well
but you can't make him do that
you can only say this is what you need
because he knows you don't like him
yeah yeah
he knows that
in his body's way of dealing with the
fact that his wife doesn't like him is
to create pains here or Phantom things
here or whatever
you see what I'm saying
yeah
I feel like we have had a lot of hard
conversations okay
um
typically they don't
sometimes I go somewhere sometimes I
don't but
I think you need some action steps at
the end because he's probably talked
about your parents a bunch and you
haven't done anything about it
yeah that's fair to say
I think well one I think moving will
help
um
don't don't forget though that doesn't
the moment well no it's just the moment
you're moving to that new house and you
get all the furniture down and the kids
go to bed
you're going to look over on the couch
and he's going to have two kleenexes
shoved up each each nostril and have a
heating pad on his neck and you're gonna
realize he went with you and you went
with you
right yeah so moving might help
proximity wise but it's not gonna solve
your marriage issues because those are
going to go with you
yeah I agree with that and if you've had
a bunch of hard conversations most of
the time I talk to folks they've not had
these conversations
if you've had them what y'all are in
desperate need is of is is action you'll
have to start acting differently
yeah I mean that's the hardest part it
is
and the only person's actions on the
planet you can control are yours so you
have to start acting different
call a counselor go to the gym
get a couple of women in your life that
you're friends with call your parents
and say we are not coming to the holiday
whatever or y'all are not welcome at
fill in the blank I don't know what the
boundaries that's probably a whole other
phone call
um
if he asks you to come look at some
weird mole or what you can respond I
don't have the medical expertise to do
that but we do have a mobile
physician and you should call them
I'm asking you I need you to not go to
Google anymore because Google
um is like pouring gasoline on this fire
in our home and you just find a thousand
different so I'd rather you talk to a
medical professional and since we have
Telehealth
um you can do that right so I need you
to
put all the screens down and just sit
with me and hold my hand and watch a
show
in the evening
I need you to put all the screens down
and just rub my shoulders in the evening
and I'll say this
um
don't cheat
don't cheat on him
I'll leave it at that just don't it's
done
you're worth more than that don't do
that
thanks for the call and I know it's
you're stuck you feel like you're Frozen
and ice and
Somebody's gotta take the first step
even if you sit down and write yourself
a letter and say Here's what I'm going
to be moving forward
but I want to be somebody that I respect
and that I treat with dignity and that
means I gotta act differently
and that starts today